in the last video we found the slope at
a particular point of the curve y is
equal to x squared but let's see if we
can generalize this and come up with a
formula that finds us the slope at any
point of the curve y is equal to x
squared so let me redraw my function
here never hurts to have a nice drawing
so that is my y-axis that is my x-axis
right there my x-axis let me draw my
curve looks something like that you've
seen that multiple times this is y is
equal to x squared so let's be very
general right now remember if we want to
find let me just write the definition of
our derivative so if we have some point
right here let's call that X so we want
to be very gentle we want to find the
slope at the point X we want to find a
function where you give me an X and I'll
tell you the slope at that point we're
going to call that f prime of x that's
going to be the derivative derivative of
f of X but all it does is look you when
you f of X you give it's a function that
you give it an X and it tells you the
value of that and we curve we draw the
curve here with f of X f of X you give
that same X but it's not going to tell
you the value of the curve it's not
going to say oh this is your f of X it's
going to say give you the value of the
slope of the curve at that point so f of
X if you put it into that function to
tell you the oh the slope at that point
is equal to you know if you put three
there you'll say oh the slope there is
equal to six we saw that in the last
example so that's what we want to do and
we saw in the last I think it was two
videos ago that we defined f prime of X
we defined F prime of X to be equal to
just the well I'll write it this way
it's the slope of the secant line
between X and some point that's a little
bit further away from X so the slope of
the secant line is change in Y so it's
the F value is the Y value of the point
that's a little bit further away from X
so f of X plus h minus the Y value at X
right because this is right here this is
f of X so minus f of X
all of that over the change in X so if
this is X plus h here the change in X is
X plus h minus X or this distance right
here is just H the change in X is going
to be equal to H so that's your slope of
the secant line between any two points
like that and we said hey we could find
the slope of the tangent line if we just
take the limit of this as it approaches
as H approaches zero limit as H
approaches zero and then we'll be
finding the slope of the tangent line
now let's apply this idea to a
particular function y is or f of X is
equal to x squared or Y is equal to x
squared so here we could have the point
this we could consider this to be the
point X x squared so f of X is just
equal to x squared and then this would
be the point this would be the point let
me do it in a more vibrant color this is
the point X plus h that's this point
right here it's a little bit further
down and then X plus h squared X plus h
squared and you know in the last video
we do this for a particular X we did it
for three but now I want a general
formula you give me any X and I want it
to do what I did in the last video for
any particular number I'll have a
general function you give me seven I'll
tell you what the slope is at seven you
give me negative three I'll tell you
what the slope is at negative three you
give me a hundred thousand I'll tell you
what the slope is at a hundred thousand
so let's apply it here so we want to
find the change in Y over the change in
X the change in Y over the change in X
so first of all the change in Y the
change in Y is this guy's Y value which
is X plus h squared X plus h squared
that's this guy's Y value right here
that's this right here that's X plus h
squared I just took X plus h evaluated I
squared it and that's that's its point
on the curve so it's X plus h squared so
that's there right there and then what's
this value f of X right here is equal to
I know it's getting messy this is equal
to x squared if you take your X you
evaluate the function at that point
you're going to get x squared so it's
equal to minus x squared this is your
change in Y that's this distance right
there
change in why I'm just to relate it to
our definition of a derivative this blue
thing right here is equivalent to this
thing right here we just evaluated our
function our function is f of X is equal
to x squared we just evaluated when X is
equal to X plus h so if you have to
square it if you have put an A there
would be a squared if I put an apple
there would be Apple squared I put an X
plus h in there it's going to be X plus
h squared so this is that thing and then
this thing right here is just the
function evaluated at the point in
question right there so this is our
change in Y and let's divide that by our
change in X our change in X if this is X
plus h and this is just X our change in
X is just going to be H so that's where
we get that term from so this is just
the slope between these two points this
is just a slope between those two points
but of course we want to find the limit
as this point gets closer and closer to
this point at this point gets closer and
closer to that point so this becomes a
tangent line so we're going to take the
limit as H approaches zero and this is
our f prime of X and this is the exact
same definition of this instead of being
general and saying for any function we
know what the function was it was f of X
is equal to x squared so we actually
applied it instead of f of X we wrote x
squared instead of f of X plus h we
wrote X plus h squared so let's see if
we can evaluate this limit so this is
going to be equal to the limit we write
a little neater than that the limit as H
approaches 0 to square this out I'll do
it in the same color that's x squared
plus 2xh plus h squared plus h squared
and then we have this minus x squared
over here minus x squared I just
multiply this guy out over here and then
all of that is divided by H now let's
see if we can simplify this a little bit
well you mean it let's see you have an x
squared and you have a minus x squared
so those cancel out and then we could
divide the numerator and the denominator
by H so this simplifies to so we get
f prime of X is equal to is equal to if
we divide the numerator and denominator
by H we get 2x plus h oh sorry I forgot
my limit it equals the limit very
important limit as H approaches zero of
divide the everything by H and you get
2x 2x plus h squared divided by H is H
if you remember the last video when we
did it with a particular X when we said
X is equal to 3 we got 6 plus Delta X
here or 6 plus h here so it's very
similar so if you take the limit as H
approaches 0 here that's just going to
disappear so this is just going to be
equal to 2x so we just figured out that
if f of X this is a big result this is
exciting that if f of X is equal to x
squared F prime of X is equal to 2x
that's what we just figured out and I
want to make sure you understand how to
interpret this f of X if you give me a
value it's going to tell you the value
of the function at that point f prime of
X is going to tell you the slope at that
point let me draw that because this is a
this is a key realization and you might
you know it's kind of maybe initially
unintuitive to think of a function that
gives us the slope at any point of
another function so it looks like this
it looks like let me draw a little
neater than that that's still not that
neat that's satisfactory let me just
draw it in the positive coordinate all
that well just draw the hope the curve
looks like something like that now this
is the curve of f of X this is the curve
of f of X is equal to x squared just
like that so if you yeah I don't know
you give me a point you give me the
point 7 you apply you put it in here you
square it and it is mapped to the number
49 it is so you get the number 49 right
there this is number 749 you're used to
dealing with functions right there but
what is f prime of 7 F prime of 7 you
say 2 times 7 is equal to 14 what is
this 14 number here what is this thing
well this is the slope of the tangent
line at X is equal to 7 so if I were to
take that point and draw a tangent line
a point a point a point that just grazes
our curve if I were to just draw a
tangent line that wasn't tangent enough
for me so that's my tangent line right
there do you get the idea the slope of
this guy you do your change in Y over
your change in X is going to be equal to
14 the slope of the curve at Y is equal
to 7 is a pretty steep curve if you
wanted to find the slope let's say that
this is y let's say it's X is equal to 2
I said X I said Y at X is equal to 7 the
slope is 14 at X is equal to 2 what is
the slope well you go you figure out F
prime of 2 which is equal to 2 times 2
which is equal to 4 so the slope here so
the slope here is 4 the slope is 4 you
could say M is equal to 4 M for slope
what is f prime of 0 F prime we know
that F of 0 is 0 right 0 squared is 0
what is f prime of 0 well 2 times 0 is 0
that's also equal to 0 but what does
that mean what's the interpretation it
means the slope of the tangent line is 0
so 0 sloped line looks like this looks
just like a horizontal line and that
looks about right that a horizontal line
would be tangent to the curve at y
equals 0 let's try another one let's try
the point minus - minus 1 so let's say
we're right there X is equal to minus 1
so f of minus 1 you just square it
because we're dealing with x squared so
it's equal to 1 that's that point right
there well what is f prime of minus 1 F
prime of minus 1 it's 2 times minus 1/2
times minus is minus 2 what does that
mean it means that the slope of the
tangent line at at X is equal to 1/2
this curve to the function is minus 2 so
if I were to draw the tangent line here
the tangent line looks like that and
look it is a downward sloping line it
makes sense the slope here the slope
here is equal to minus 2
you